[Music]
hey everybody Conan O'Brien here with a
brand new edition of clueless gamer this
is an exciting one
watchdogs most highly anticipated game
of this summer we're getting a sneak
peek joining me once again and wearing
glasses for the first time is Aaron
Blair
my cyber Chum hello your glasses look
good you look like a Swiss clock maker
and PlayStation 4 if this game looks
beautiful it takes advantage of all the
sweet sweet power of the ps4 they
actually made a brand new engine for
this game incredible in the disrupt
engine so there's crazy physics and I
don't care this game takes place in a
futuristic Chicago is it the near future
or far future and it's near future in
this game the city is run by one giant
operators one operating system runs the
entire city our city so things like
traffic lights city services all this
stuff we can hack into in control this
is us right here and this is what a
jacket looks like in the near future
right there's a leather bandaid that
holds it together look at this that
camera up there we can hack into this
camera Wow
you can see what security cameras see on
an average day when nothing's happening
oh wait here press up press square you
could blow that steam pipe why do that
yeah why I don't know good I don't think
everything should be on one computer in
Chicago I think that's a very bad idea
like I was probably just trying to play
Coldplay on my phone tonight Loula
ooh pack this guy so press the square
button yep okay would you like to make
the exchange know where I'll send you a
location to leave bag we're gonna go get
the bag before he does so right when we
steal his car there you go we got to get
to the package before anyone else you
know what not my god this is a rental
when I go to Hertz and rent a car this
is how I treat it it's upstairs got a
bunch of chemicals okay so I got some
look at this is very nihilistic look
he's like where where is there really to
go in life oh I want to ride that thing
oh yeah oh I know I look cool this is
the appropriate vehicle for this jacket
get out I'll make the deliveries now you
don't have to do is steal this truck and
then make the same deliveries
and actually be hired by UPS sorry
packages to deliver you know what this
is what I'm doing right now this is a
FedEx commercial if you go with UPS this
is the kind of service year
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you a great way to get around yeah
I could just call me into that boat you
can just go over there and climb up in
it nice there you go come on
is that a woman I don't want to hurt her
can I make out with theirs make out
button why is this woman in a housecoat
look what she's wearing
who goes boating in that outfit that's
just the pressure even make eye contact
we just stumbled upon Sylvia Plath in a
boat I just shot a woman for no I'm
sorry
yes oh there buddy oh there's another
crime where crime you know I'm not not
good at video games we got to get there
before the crime happens oh jesus no
don't wait pull your gun out way to
solve a crime why are you shooting in
the streets that's the best way to solve
a crime sometimes is to start a new
crime oh there goes our car taking this
car what is this that's green yeah can't
catch me
I'm gonna shoot you they're gonna shoot
you what happened well you drove a new
graveyard and ran into a bunch of cops
and shot at some trees and then they
kill you
yeah but I'm already at the graveyard in
the name of the middle man sound of our
hideout here the face of our operations
we're passing the city system we can see
all the stuff that's going on throughout
the city so he can watch anything
happening anywhere in the city
yeah let me ask you a question because
they know people watching right now are
wondering can you watch people have sex
and is that part of the game yes you can
watch people have sex it's implied the
sex is implied but no you don't actually
see any
this okay so turn around and we get
patchiness of the videos we can hack
into this mainframe oh man I love that
videogames have finally fold in on
themselves we've gone from the action
used to be slay the dragon right yeah
now it's let's go into a basement and
play with computers I'm gonna introduce
our IT expert here at the Conan show
Chris Hayes Christian mind stepping in
here for a second Chris good to see it
now Chris let me ask you quickly is
there what do you think of an entire
city that is running off one program do
you think that's plausible did that ever
happen that would be the worst design
possibly it would be because it allowed
guy like this to have you in there
everything like he is right but it's
Chicago someone had proposed this and
someone else said that's not a good idea
in a guy one don't worry a body good
well thank you so much for your
technical expertise and he was going to
shake my hands so that is so much good
Chris is going to show
and state so watchdogs what do you think
alright it'll blow your mind watchdogs
coming out May 27th if you're a cool
dude
you'll love it if you're a hacker who
likes to stay in a basement and play
around with people's adjustable rate
mortgage you'll really love clueless
gamer Elizabeth waters so we have